Speaker 1: Let's stick in Michigan for
a little bit and go to Trent from Ann
Arbor. Trent from Ann Arbor, welcome to
the program. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 3: Hi, David. Can you hear me all right?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 3: Hey, first want to say I've been hoping
to get in and talk to you for a while now. I've
been watching for almost a year. I love what you
do. Really great. Definitely. I would love to see
more voices out there and do what you do. Thank
you. I wanted to talk about. I know you've been
covering like the other Republicans, jumping in on
the primaries and stuff, and you've been talking
about a lot about like, what they're doing. Makes
no sense, right? I fully agree. It's like you
can't get enough voters with Trump in the running.
And I generally believe that most of them are
banking on Trump dropping out for one reason or
another. So I just wanted your thoughts on that,
because that's the only way. Like, the only thing
I can understand them wanting them, doing it the
way they're doing it, the way they're doing.
Speaker 1: I don't think you're wrong. Trend in
the sense that one idea about what's so there's
a couple different ways that you could try to
win a Republican primary. You could try to win a
Republican primary by activating all the people
that already don't like Trump. Or you could win
a Republican primary by trying to convince people
who like Trump to vote for you instead of Trump
or some combination of these. Okay, So these are
a couple different strategies. If you're trying
to get the people who don't like Trump to vote for
you, then you're going to have to criticize Trump.
And so far, the only guy who's really criticizing
Trump is Chris Christie. DeSantis A little bit,
but it's really Chris Christie who has said,
I get it, this nomination goes through Trump. So
that's one approach. The other approach is, okay,
if I sort of just draw some distinctions with how
I think things should be done, but don't really
insult Trump. If Trump gets arrested multiple
more times and then it just takes him off the
campaign trail and whatever, I can be here,
sort of like Jerry in the episode where he's
hanging around the woman who just had a break up,
right? He's like, I'll just I'll be there for you,
and then I'll just be there, you know? The problem
is, DeSantis has 20 something. So if DeSantis is
already doing that, how is Tim Scott at 2% going
to do the exact same thing? Is that the math? They
can't all do it, you know? So I don't I don't know
what the dynamics of that primary will look like
in 4 to 6 weeks, particularly now with Christie
in who my guess is will get at least attention
for going after Trump. It'll be interesting
to see what it looks like in a month or two.
Speaker 3: Well, And I guess I guess my last
point is and to extend it further, I just don't
understand how people can be so dense. Like, you
know, I look and I see what they're all saying
and the just general Republican talking points,
you know, how how dangerously we've you know,
we've been on the edge of losing our democracy.
Yeah. And I'm just sitting here like, how are
you all complacent with this thing? Like, why
are we why is there not or outrage and or vocal
outrage? Why can't at a certain point we just say,
stop, you can't do this. You can't lie and bring
down our democracy to suit your own needs?
Speaker 1: I don't totally get it. I don't
totally get it. And it's part of the I mean,
complacency or even support for that. I mean,
there's still people who say Trump won. There's
still people who defend the rioters from January
6th. That's a much bigger conversation, Trent.
But bottom line, it's a mess. It's a mess.
Speaker 3: But I fully agree now.
Speaker 1: All right. Well,
sorry to end on such a disappointing note, but
I do appreciate. Thank you, David. All right.
There is traps from Ann Arbor. Listen, let's
get out of Michigan now, because we've we've
been going to show it. No offense to Michigan, but
we've got to go to some other state, I feel like.